دعونا الان مشاهدينا ان نعود سويا لما حدث
بتاريخ الرابع من اغسطس من العام 2020 اي
منذ لحظه انفجار مرفق بيروت يعتقد ان سبب
الانفجار هو حريق نشب في احد المستودعات
والتسع مسببا انفجار مئات الاصنام مني
تراث الامونيوم المواد الكيميائيه هذه
كانت متجهه في الاصل الى موزمبيق على متن
سفينه مستاجره من روسيا لكنها سوودرت عام
2013 مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكيه
خلصا الى ان كميه اثبات الامونيوم التي
انفجرت هي حمص الكميه المقدره ب
2754 ظنا ما عزت الشكوك بشان فقدان كميات
كبيره من الشحنه اما من كان يعلم بهذه
الشحنه هم مسؤولون لبنانيون كبار من بينهم
الرئيس السابق ميشيل عون ورئيس الوزراء
انذاك حسن الدياب كما ذكرت منظمته من بعيد
انا مسؤولين اميين وحكميين كبارا كانت
لديهم تقارير عن الخطر لكنهم لن يقوم باي
تحرك اما بالنسبه لمسار التحقيق بقضيه
المرفق فواجه معوقات منذ اللحظه الاولى
بسبب الضغط السياسي على القضاء اول
المحققين القادم صوان وجهتهامات
لثلاثه وزراء سابقين وحسان دياب بالاهمال
لكنه وجهها بعد ذلك ضغوطا قويه وابعد
بعدها من القضيه في فبراير 20 21 بعد ان
شكا اثنان من الوزراء السابقين وهما علي
حسن خليل وغازي زعيتر من تجاوز السلطاتهم
اما البيطار الذي عدنا خلفا لصوان سعى
لاستجواب للشخصيات البارزه من بينها خليل
وسيدر حتى وصلت تحقيق الى مرحله من
النسيان التام في 20 22 الى الحين استانف
البيطار تحقيقه هذا الاسبوع بناء على راي
القانوني ووجهها نتهامات لمسؤولين بينهم
مدير عام الامن العام اللواء عباس ابراهيم
لم يلاحق البطار اي من اعضاء حزب الله لكن
الاخير جنه حمله شرسه ضده بعد ما سعى
لاستجواب خلفاء له